but why shouldn't iMessage plug into
xntp and get more secure more encrypted
and more decentralized communication so
people can own it imagine a gray bubble
in the future instead of a green bubble
alongside your blue bubble that is
actually the more secure way to reach
any other application outside of the
iMessage ecosystem
all right guys bang bang I've got Shane
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is there's this big big problem
in the crypto world that most people
don't understand unless you are an
active user of many of the products uh
or applications and it's this private
direct messaging the ability for one
wallet to communicate with another uh
you guys are building a solution for it
but explain like what is the problem why
is this such a big thing that no one has
seemed to be able to crack at yeah it's
a good question let's go back to how it
started so a few years ago you know I've
been in messaging for almost 15 years
now and building on top of mostly web 2
platforms SMS messenger WhatsApp and
seeing the whole rise of kind of
centralized messaging and Robert
leschner who was the CEO and the
co-founder of compound Labs probably one
of the biggest D5 platforms to 2020 so
right around pandemic time you came to
Matt and I and we were just kind of
thinking about ideas I you know I was in
a lockup from my last company to get
acquired Matt wasn't sure what he wanted
to do yet because he his last time we
had acquired by Kraken and we both are
passionate about communication and I
didn't really see it I was like why
would you talk to a wallet et cetera and
Robert said to us listen guys I have 11
billion dollars in a smart contract I
know every single person's address and I
can't send a message to them he's like
imagine a bank had every customer in
their bank and they couldn't send him an
email he's like it's a huge problem he's
like I need to be able to communicate I
need to tell them about staking
liquidation events coming new regulation
that's happening with compound the
government's probably going to have
regulation that they're going to require
us to send to say hey you're an investor
in this new D5 protocol and pooled like
here's the documents none of that exists
he's like trillions of dollars are sent
between wallet addresses every day and
you can't send an email because what
ultimately his problem was is uh there
was a product and basically these were
users of that product and it's the
company uh or the product can't
communicate with those users usually
when people think of private messaging
they're thinking like two random users
on the internet want to communicate with
each other outside of companies products
Etc but this actually started because it
was somebody saying hey I have all these
people using this there's tons of
economic value here but I can't
communicate with the people who are
essentially the customer commercial or
the product users huge problem and I
think easier to understand why that's a
problem versus maybe two individuals who
just want to communicate with each other
totally I think the peer-to-peer use
case is actually kind of hard to see
right now you're like WhatsApp works
great iMessage works great because your
identity is already there so the
question is is there a new identity and
if there is communication protocols
usually follow and I think what's
happening is the wallet address is
becoming the new identity and there's
new interactions where that is the only
thing that's used so in this scenario
Robert lesser didn't have your email a
lot of web 3 and D5 and all of the
crypto space actually the wallet is the
login that's the whole point you own it
your assets now you can own your
communication with that wallet login and
I think what's happening is whenever you
have that new identity pop up there's
new relationships that form in those new
relationships enable a new communication
protocol and that's kind of like where
we're at in the shift and I think it
started in a very b2c type use case like
I'm a D5 protocol and I need to talk to
these 12 000 wallet holders because the
only thing I have are people giving me
money and they're walled address how can
I talk to them and that really kind of
like was the spark of the idea and
around the same time Mike Shinoda from
Linkin Park was on a clubhouse back in
2020 when we're all just hanging out you
know everyone's just sitting at home
drinking wine and you're like what is
going to happen in the world and he's
like talking about the day he got rugged
by Facebook they had the largest
Facebook audience in the world at one
time and he was like all of a sudden I
couldn't reach any fans and when he saw
the nft he didn't see like oh make money
on this art and stuff he saw hey this
nft gives me a wallet address that
addresses public on a ledger if I have a
million people that own my nft can
anyone take that audience from me can
anyone take those million addresses that
are like have a basically a connection
and a consent mechanism to say hey I
have a tie to this community I own your
token and he's like no and that was like
the spark when Matt called me he's like
hey something's happening here with this
D5 stuff but also now this nft stuff's
happening where I think there's a new
relationship that is going to form and
that was really what it was then and
today I think it's grown a lot where I
see it as a whole different mechanism by
which the next whatsapps of the world
are going to be built on top of
decentralized Technology like an xmtp
but back then that's really how it
started with solving that problem so
when you kind of zoom out for a second
right now I'm going to use the term
crypto to describe an entire industry
but there's obviously various protocols
there's different D5 products there's
kind of all the the fragmentation that
you would expect to kind of pop up when
there's new technology and Innovation
happening where did you guys kind of
initially start right there's Bitcoin
there's ethereum and then there's like
this long tail of other uh smart
contract platforms then there's all the
products like how did you guys think
about initially starting and just saying
like how does this work totally I go
back to the Robert Lessner story and
really the D5 world and the NFC kind of
thing so we started in the evm world but
we're not on chain messaging because it
doesn't scale and it's actually not that
private or secure and so it's using the
public private key pair of the wallets
to enable communication between the
wallets but because it's not on chain
it's not dependent on evm so we could do
it on bitcoin on Solana it doesn't
really matter but this is really an
important data point I think because
um uh for those that don't know you can
put messages on a blockchain right you
started there actually and and there are
messages that are you know stupid things
that people kind of put in and it's
funny whatever uh people have written uh
inscriptions into uh various uh
blockchains because they're announcing
uh they want to kind of cement the
company Milestone or something like that
there's even been cases where I think in
China uh there was some freedom of
speech and uh there was like an incident
on a college campus around sexual
assault and one of the people kept
getting censored so they literally just
wrote it into the ethereum blockchain
and became this like you know kind of
national uh thing but you guys are not
actually doing that because
you said it's not private I'm assuming
it's expensive to some degree on some of
these changes this doesn't really scale
okay explain kind of like why can't you
do it on the blockchain even though you
could write messages on the blockchain
totally and people are actually doing it
where like you know almost like when you
send an nft and you can put metadata on
it right they're doing it in that way
but when you think about privacy and
security and if you care about that and
when we talk to every developer in the
industry all of them are like I want
private and secure messaging and if you
start thinking about the metadata that
comes along with that so who's talking
to who when our message is sent all that
stuff is on a blockchain and to make
that private you really can't use a
blockchain to do that and so it's been
very intentional to actually use the
wallets and the public private key pair
as the mechanism by which you're sending
and verifying who you are but the
messages are sent in off-chain way to
protect privacy and security and to be
able to scale
when you look at how it's built today
what exactly is happening so do I have
my wallet which has all of my assets and
then I've got like a separate inbox
where I'm receiving messages and sending
them or how is like the user experience
of the wallet holder yeah so there's
over two uh 250 applications already
built on top of xmtp and you can think
of it like an email client an iMessage
client I actually have this app on my
phone that I use for xmtp that is
literally iMessage
for xmtp and it looks like iMessage
and it is iMessage and what's changing
is
the application layer can be anything so
it can look like an email client it
could look like an iMessage client it
can look like a DM Client where the
entire DM layer of lens so if you use
any lens ecosystem map it's like a
decentralized Twitter the DM layer is
xmtp and it allows you to communicate
within anyone within the lens ecosystem
but in this world with any wallet in the
entire ecosystem so let's take uh the
xmtp client that you have that looks
like iMessage on your phone that's a
company called Converse that built that
okay so Converse if I'm using that and I
say I want to send a message to you
what's happening I type into my phone
right what is kind of the the uh
sequence of events between when I type
into the phone and you actually receive
the message totally so first off is
identity so you're picking an identity
and mapping it to your wallet address
usually you don't have to you can use
the ZRX address that's fine I'm typing
in chainmack.eth it's resolving to my
wallet address then I'm typing picking
up a message in the app the app is then
encrypting it it's fully into and
encrypted and we want to like shoot for
Signal protocol level encryption right
like that's really the goal here is to
get to that level so that
um everyone has that out of the box and
they plug into the network it's sent
through the nodes the node operators are
actually where you get to where it
becomes decentralized and so they're
delivering the message to the other
client and the private key on the other
side is the only thing that can access
the message so the private key is
actually the decryption mechanism and
the the thing that's changing here is in
the past
take WhatsApp for example log in with
WhatsApp is their identity
their app their servers right in this
world you can use any identity that Maps
your wallet address any application
in a decentralized network like xmc so
any identity means that uh let's say for
example
um Facebook for a while it became a huge
thing that uh you couldn't get a
four-letter uh identification anymore so
facebook.com whatever username uh you
would have to know somebody at the
company to get four letters right uh
five letters if it was available you
could have it if it was six letters
whatever but four letters or less they
wouldn't give it to you because they
decided that that wasn't a identity that
they thought was applicable to their
service here whether it's one letter 20
letters whatever name dot lens as long
as you just map it to the wallet address
exactly you can use it now and it's
decentralized so the ens community.eth
right the lens Community I'm Shane
mac.lens the Unstoppable domains like it
doesn't matter and so you just have to
know what it is right but then you own
that and you own that identity and I
think that's a pretty major shift where
you can take your identity with you and
if you think think about like what's
really interesting is the same way a
wallet can access your assets
in the way we're constructed and how
this works any application can access
your communication and if today you're
using an app and the only way to get
your messages is through that same app
you don't own your communication
um and then through the application
itself like you're using this one
specifically for this one client but
really the idea is that you could have
any client uh anywhere built now can I
go across clients right it's like one of
the things
um that I think when people start
understanding the silos and finance
they're like if I have PayPal and you
have cash app I can't send you money
totally right so there's these siled
kind of uh Payment Systems obviously the
promise of some of these Technologies
like Bitcoin lightning network uh other
platforms is now there's
interoperability so if you're using
client a and somebody else using client
B if they're both plugged into lightning
Network for example then they can send
between those platforms is the same
thing true with messaging here and
across these different uh applications
totally that's exactly right it's it's
actually the magic of the whole thing
it's a portable inbox so when I go to
the lens app there's one called orb that
I like it's awesome it's a beautiful app
click DMS it's the same DMS that show up
in Converse and the moment that you sign
your with your key and the private key
to Crypts and you can take your messages
with you to any application I think is
the aha moment where people go oh yeah I
have 12 messaging apps on my phone I
can't get anything out of there I don't
own the relationships I don't own the
network I don't own the data I don't own
the identity and I'm stuck within this
ecosystem and I can't take anything with
me and that's kind of the fundamental
shift is can we build a global private
secure messaging like Network and
protocol where thousands of applications
can be built in the next whatsapps the
next twilio's the next send grids the
next billion dollar companies are built
on top of xmtp now you said that the
messages go through the various nodes uh
what nodes are those so today xmtp Labs
our company runs the nodes we're working
really hard to get decentralized so that
other parties are running nodes and have
a test net running by H2 and at that
point the nodes will be ran by Third
parties delivering that you know they're
just servers that are delivering
messages but they're incentivized by the
the applications paying into the
ecosystem to fund the nodes that are
actually a decentralized network to
deliver the messages and make sure that
they're delivered in a secure way and so
the idea would be that me as a user
let's say a sender of a message you as a
recipient we're not picking which node
path or anything like that it's
literally just the nodes are able to get
the message from me to you and even if
at some point it's intercepted or
delivered to somebody else it's all
encrypted so without the private keys
from your wallet no one else can read
that message exactly yeah well how do
you think about
um the response from the signals from
the iMessages from the uh you know
various messaging platforms like a
WhatsApp whatever when they see these
types of Technologies are they
interested in them are they trying to
figure it out or is it just so far
outside of what they do that you know
it's kind of classic innovators dilemma
no I actually see it they're we're like
so inspired by a signal and even
WhatsApp is built on the signal protocol
right but because their own in the app
WhatsApp that's where they get all the
metadata or signal actively chooses not
to collect metadata and same with us we
actually have a really strong intention
around what we don't collect right what
we don't see and I think that's very
important at the protocol level to let
that happen at the application Level but
I see a future take this like signal
just got rid of SMS so they just threw
out SMS they used to support it so you
could get your SMS messages and signal
but they're unencrypted it's a shitty
old technology but it is interoperable
right EU is coming in with pretty strict
new privacy laws and whether you agree
with them or not if you watch the signal
kind of President Meredith she had a
great talk about how it's kind of like
encroaching on privacy and it's really
kind of like coming against the ability
to have an interoperable and private
layer so she's making the claim that the
Privacy enhancing regulation from the
view of the legislators is actually
hurting privacy yes in some weird way
explain that a little bit but so but let
me break this down with signal because
what I think is interesting is
if they want to have an interoperable
layer
where they can communicate to any
identity that is more owned by people
because they believe in security privacy
and ownership
then having a secure layer that's not
SMS that could be xmtp that signal app
could just plug into and now the
messages that are through the xmtp
network or to wallets could be right in
the inbox alongside the people within
your signal application makes tons of
sense to me or even iMessage the green
bubble in the future to me if we're
successful this has nothing to do with
web3 web 3 is the starting point because
there's a real problem and there's a new
identity that needs communication but
why shouldn't iMessage plug into xntp
and get more secure more encrypted and
more decentralized communication so
people can own it imagine a gray bubble
in the future instead of a green bubble
alongside your group blue bubble that is
actually the more secure way to reach
any other application outside of the
iMessage ecosystem when you send
messages through this type of kind of
messaging protocol do I have to pay for
the messages like is there some sort of
cost to it or is it being essentially
subsidized by the various applications
and they're the one really kind of
paying for the ability to communicate
yeah today we hope to always have free
for users like they shouldn't have to
pay to communicate and the applications
will fund the node operations to scale I
think the business models live in the
mass senders the spam mitigation how to
disincentivize spam using economics and
if you get into like if I want to send
100 000 messages to a bunch of wallet
addresses there's a new consent
mechanism that should be invented in the
future that we've actually researched
we're working on a lot we call it
postage that I think is really where the
monetization comes from which is people
like marketers wanting to reach your
attention there should be a you know a
monetization model built into that I
love having these conversations because
I'm an investor and I don't even know
everything you guys are working on so
I'm getting live updates right now
that's great this is my investor update
yeah perfect explain this postage
concept a little bit more yeah I mean
think about it really simply as we're
going from a privacy world to a consent
world
the past was privacy and there's a lot
of laws around you got to use ads to get
people's data get them to opt in and
then send them messages right and people
spend all their money to get access to
that in this world the addresses are
actually public
so what actually matters now and I think
is where to innovate is giving people
more control over their inbox by putting
in consent layers and so it's already
happening developers have built token
gated chat developers have built
actually full filtering so you can say
if um you don't have one eth in your
wallet you can't reach my wallet and
they started to add in all these things
but in the future you can imagine the
protocol very simply could have a
dynamic fee for each wallet based on the
value of that wallet to the sender and
if you want to send 500 000 messages and
take someone's attention there's a cost
to that and that is how the ecosystem
much like you think today
um in kind of like the way the ad
networks work but what we don't want to
ever do ads we want to actually invent a
new model that is around consent that
gives people more control but at the
same time values their attention so I
think there's a whole new kind of
mechanism here that gives people a lot
more control over their attention and
the protocol itself can like value you
more specifically value each wallet
versus like hey it cost you know
MailChimp 10 000 emails cost this yeah
actually every wallet has a unique value
so is there even a way that you could
like split it like hey cost X dollars or
whatever to send 100 000 messages and
then if they're red you pay you know X
plus 20 and if they act it's X Plus 40
or something because like you really do
have the ability to know who it is but
then you see the actions like the
actions end up being you know quote
unquote on chain and so you could almost
uh I think of it kind of like sending
emails is one thing but like really the
valuable ones the ones that are opened
but even the more valuable ones are the
ones where people clicked totally and so
you could almost create like some sort
of metered ability uh and again these
businesses paying for this stuff right
but like they're likely to want to pay a
lot more if I know hey somebody's gonna
open the email they're gonna click on
that link and they're gonna go to my
website that's a way different
conversation than like maybe they open
it maybe they don't what I'm paying
either way right totally there's so many
things to innovate on on that layer
um especially like the relationship
that's formed you could imagine if I
voted for a doubt imagine there's like a
yes no button we call them content types
inside the message and you knew that I
voted on chain for the for a thing that
someone asked me to vote for that's a
very valuable interaction and so the
cost of that could be very different you
could even innovate the other way which
is Imagine people were like I really
wanted to talk to you I'm not going to
take your money right you can innovate
both ways where almost like staking you
could almost give it back Etc I think
the most important thing though is the
protocol itself it's very important for
what we don't collect because the red
States and when you get into all that
area it's very uh kind of we have to be
very intentionable intentional about
what applications can see of metadata
and what they can't see and what we
can't see like because if you're just
giving all of that metadata away at the
um at the application Level that might
not be a good thing and so we've spent a
lot of time at the protocol level really
trying to just like keep privacy and
security for at the Forefront but then
the applications I think that layer
might live on top of it where they can
decide based on actions that happen on
chain or more meaningful actions or
consent or they say this is a great
message whatever can create the
economics it's interesting because
basically at the protocol level if you
guys aren't collecting any of this
information you don't have access to it
but if an application basically is able
to collect it kind of before it gets to
the protocol then they have access to
whatever they're collecting and so as a
user if you're uh worried about privacy
or or really want to spend time making
sure that you have private
Communications you not just have to
worry about uh what is the protocol but
you have to understand what is the
application layer for sure that I'm
using and also I'm assuming you have to
have some understanding of what is the
application layer that the recipient of
my message is using because there may be
some way for that application to be
collecting metadata as well right
exactly I mean imagine a future
that is enabled by xmtp so the world can
have a private and secure messaging
layer and someone buys a company and one
individual can now read your unencrypted
DMs that can't happen you can just leave
you can take all of your encrypted
messaging
with you and leave that application and
I think that's a very powerful like
um shift in the world that puts power
and ownership back to people
um talk a little bit about what some of
the use cases are like why do people
need to message these wallets so you
mentioned kind of the b2c use case of
hey I have a product there's much people
using it I need to communicate with them
I don't have an ability to do that you
guys help solve that problem what are
some of the other use cases that like an
individual user would say I need to be
able to communicate either with wallets
or I want to use this type of protocol
for those Communications totally I think
the first one go back to the b2c case if
you look at how the mobile World played
out messaging and communication was
actually the entire retention layer
so every application couldn't get
retention messaging actually was the
retention layer and I think that same
phase is happening right now
dapps are out there people have a lot of
users if you look at the metrics of the
last three years people logging in with
email is going down people logging in
with while it is going up so as wallets
become the identity people want to
control their identity and the adapson
applications actually want the the
wallet address as your login
you need a way to communicate because
you need a way to get people to come
back to your application and I think
that notification that notification
re-engagement layer is actually probably
one of the like most powerful use cases
that every application within the next
two years in web 3 crypto Etc will be
able to re-engage and have a
relationship with users that they just
don't have today and the you know the
other ones are like way more interesting
and cool there's a lot of people OTC
swap which built one where it's actually
trading nfts but you can do the trading
and swapping inside of the conversation
I actually feel like
crypto isn't that big and the owning
your conversations could be bigger than
owning your assets
and the conversation drives Commerce
more than Commerce drives the
conversation and I think that's always
been true and the missing piece of
crypto is that the conversation is
happening in chaos all over and you see
all these public wallet is this your
public wall who's this public wallet
people just throwing zero X addresses
all over Discord and and I think
the trust that it can enable to allow
for these new types of use cases where
you're doing Commerce as part of the
conversation and it's more trusted is a
is it picking a huge World someone else
just built a loan application and the
loan is actually done all through the
conversation but because the content
types they can yes no on chains execute
the loan within the chat which is really
cool to see what a lot of the Legacy
companies are trying to do right they
are trying to
um enhance chat functionality they're
trying to drastically reduce the
friction for the person who's on the
company side of the chat to be able to
execute different things one of the most
fast needing statistics uh and I'm going
to get the numbers wrong so I don't want
to misspeak but uh Peloton actually
sells hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of pelotons via their chat
which you would think like wait what do
you mean what ends up happening is that
most of these companies historically
have looked at the chat functionality on
a website as a customer service
mechanism so somebody's got a problem
they write in they're thinking about
potentially buying something they've got
a question you know whatever
can't find their order you know all the
things that people use the chat for but
Peloton and I'm sure other companies but
they're the one that I'm familiar with
uh actually looked at is no this is our
this is our sales team and so when you
write in we want you to buy things and
they looked at it as more like an
offensive opportunity and so they were
able to drastically enhance these sales
experience uh and conversion in that
chat well I'm sure they were doing all
kinds of stuff on the back end to figure
out how the hell do we get people who
are in this chat uh from our side and
are kind of helping to uh educate our
customers one click to be allowed to do
sales convert whatever but you're still
going through a legacy system right and
so even though let's say I'm on the
company side you're the customer
you're sitting there chatting and okay
you're gonna purchase now like it's
still going through our Legacy stuff if
I usually that's a link to the website
right whatever right like now all of a
sudden if we can basically execute that
sale right there in the chat it's the
virtual uh um you know comparison to
like you're at the store I come over
with a little register right like an
Apple Store like there's no leaving once
they decide that you're gonna buy
totally like they coming to you you're
just staying right here at the table and
just execute and so it's very similar I
think in terms of you know this ability
of you're not setting them and hoping
that they convert on the website or
going through the payment flow or
anything that can happen right there in
the chat it's pretty powerful hey guys
what's going on I hope that you're
enjoying this conversation but I want to
interrupt for a quick second and tell
you about a brand new conference that
I'm hosting on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center the event is
called lyceum Miami and tickets are
completely free for anyone who wants to
come I'm bringing together many of the
most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
or Delian and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation
totally and I think your Apple Store
analogy is very cool because the wallet
is the Apple Store of crypto and web3
and what's changed is that the Commerce
is now enabled inside the wallet and
communication is going to be as well and
I think if you think about the wallets
as the gateway to Commerce you can think
about the wallets as also the key to
communication and the fact that those
are together that's where this all
changes when you look at
um some of these decentralized social
networking that's popping up
um that there's one uh now I'm gonna
mispronounce but Nostra not nostro
however you want to pronounce it that's
been in the top 10 The Social Network
downloads there's a number of other ones
that have popped up over the years
there's obviously land
and others what are they getting right
and what do they still need to improve
on but like when you kind of look at it
because you guys are a messaging layer
and ultimately uh kind of wallet to
wallet communication is a form of social
networking right it's kind of private
you know direct messaging
um but it seems like many of these
platforms are trying to take it a step
further and create more of one-to-many
communications and and really kind of
build up the social network
functionality what do you think they're
getting right and what do you think that
they still need to kind of enhance or
improve on totally and you know we work
with lens directly and we're the DM
layer of lens so when you use any lens
app and you go to send a DM you can send
a DM to anyone within the lens ecosystem
but you can also send a DM to Shane
mac.ieth and that kind of shows you the
interoperability of the whole space but
when you look at the space I think the
first thing on the what is it getting
right is it's following a macro Trend
that people want when you see Noster in
the top 10 in the App Store I think
people are grasping that they want to
own their like Network and their
identity and be able to take it with
them and not have it in the hands of a
centralized like single company
especially with everything happening
around Facebook and Twitter Etc when you
see one person buy a company take it
private and like
they get to make any decision for that
company whether you like it or not it's
like damn that's that's crazy that one
person can actually own all this and
read my DMs that I've sent since 2007.
you know it's kind of like one of those
moments in history and so the fact that
these are all popping up I think people
are starting to grasp it and the idea
that you can own and control your
identity your network and your
communication is a pretty radical idea
that wasn't possible without the
infrastructure that's been built here
the thing that we're getting wrong and
I'm not going to say any of the networks
is the ux is yeah the user
experience because you the wallet logins
weren't built for mobile the app stores
aren't playing along well Apple doesn't
really see that yet the consumer use
cases of messaging and social and owning
your communication and having a better
SMS than you have an iMessage like
they're not there yet so the app stores
are you know making it hard to use
wallets and publish things and the
wallet addresses are having a hard time
doing the logins and the Deep linking
between apps is broken I mean it's I'll
like punch myself in the face trying to
log into these apps with like 10
different signatures and you're like why
is this so hard and it just reminds me
though of you know I've been in
technology since the beginning of like
the social era and it feels like that
right it feels like Twitter is just on
SMS and you're like I can't search
anything I can't do anything I'm just
tweeting to The Ether here in 23232 and
some dudes responding to me on Twitter
in 2006 like we're there
um but because we went through this like
Golden Era of amazing mobile
applications it kind of feels like we're
starting over and it's really painful
the user experience and user interfaces
I've said for a long time now are
atrocious and I've always wondered is it
because the design Talent hasn't yet
kind of gotten excited and moved over uh
that might have been true three four
five years ago now I see a number of
very talented designers who are starting
to come over a lot of product people
things that like you're like okay you
know how to build products now can you
figure out this specific problem let's
see but like you have the skill set and
the experience but there's also like
what I'll call like um some maybe like
infrastructure type challenges so for
example human readable domains versus uh
kind of the ox
wallet addresses like I was talking to a
group last night and I literally was
like dude I don't know why people won't
say it but like there's times where I go
to send a transaction my heart's pumping
a little bit right you know like you
know Palms are weak or palms are sweaty
or whatever right there I'm lying like
you're like I hope this gets
totally I hope I didn't make a mistake
and so obviously if even people who are
doing this on a day-to-day basis are
dealing with that like it's Gotta
improve and so I do wonder how much of
that is like one designer or one product
team can actually make some of these
changes I think what you're talking
about like definitely we we need
Improvement but also it seems like we
almost need kind of ecosystem buy-in to
really kind of shift some of these as
well to make it so that somebody off the
street who doesn't know anything about
technology can use these products and
seamless easy to do
um and ultimately I think will just lead
to kind of more usage more adoption
right totally and it's happening I mean
if you look at the rainbow team or you
look at the orb app on lens
um there's there's a lot of other apps
on lens that are actually really good as
well and the entire ecosystem of apps is
starting to get a lot better the problem
is actually in the setup and the
onboarding into the world
so the apps have gotten better now the
designers I think have come and there's
a lot of great applications but the
start to I'm now sending my first
message of go to ens and go tell me how
long it takes you to get an ens name
right it's like what is ens what are
their three steps for why am I waiting
two minutes to verify this what's a
transaction how do I get e to my wallet
to buy this stupid name like there's so
the Gap is so big and I watch it all the
time versus that part of it I think has
to shift identity the ability to use a
wallet and the ability to send a message
or send an asset I think will all come
together I think the wallets are doing a
pretty decent job like starting to
innovate here but that has to happen
rainbow did a great job with DNS name so
now inside of the rainbow wallet you can
easily buy an ensam and it actually
feels like really slick so it's a cool
to see them integrate like an open
protocol like ens into their app at the
great ux but you still have to go
through the entire hurdle of getting
your ethereum into the wallet and like
all that so until the kind of
onboarding is improved I think that's
the thing that we need to spend a lot of
time on yeah the other piece
um feels like uh social networks have to
be driven by density like you you need
the network there right there's a whole
point of why you come and uh we've seen
a number of networks explode and then
kind of falter right and explode in
hindsight actually isn't nearly that big
what do you think is kind of that
Tipping Point like when you guys have
seen some of these applications is it
there's like an aha moment right I think
slacks aha moment was like 2500 messages
between a team right and then it's like
they're not leaving right Facebook uh
notorious cameras 10 people in seven
days or seven people in 10 days whatever
it was that you friended it was like 85
likely that you're staying as a retained
user have you guys seen anything around
those data points in terms of messaging
uh whether it's through social networks
applications anything like that where
people once they start using it they're
not going to leave yeah it's an
interaction success within the first
like 25 seconds of activating the inbox
interesting so like do I even get a
response right and so we've actually
coming from the the social and messaging
world it's it's kind of like we're
obsessed with network effects and
interaction and success internally as
our driving force and mapping the
interactions to the overlap of
communities is something we take very
seriously so if I know that lenses in
the ecosystem it's all public data so in
this world I can actually know the
overlap of Lynn's wallets to the ens
community and I can walk into the NS
community and say by the way 35 of the
people
in the ens Community are already on xmtp
and so you actually know where those
overlaps happen and I think you can
build Network effects where you can
increase interaction success
in a proactive way that's never been
possible because of on-chain data and
that's a very huge opportunity I think
to build better Network effects where
you don't end up in the like I never got
a response I just got on this network I
sent a message no one's running back it
didn't really work
um and I think that's where you can end
up if you were just like I'm just going
for wallet addresses or yeah we have
five million wallets and you can spin up
wallets in an hour yeah um so you really
have to I think get into that the
interaction success works right when you
get on it you know that another person's
on the network we can suggest that much
like the social networks you know they
were like here's your 10 friends the
Twitter was like here's people to fall
you had to like get that right and I
think we need to also get that right
with knowing the ecosystems you're a
part of so that you know you're in a
trust it I know that you're also a
person with the ens or you're also in
the Pro app Community or you're also in
the lens community and making sure that
you're connecting those people to have a
quick interaction success so they're
like oh this inbox works yeah I think
it's very important what are the
challenges with this like the risks of
people starting to use these types of
protocols right like you guys are
obviously building uh one that is
probably the most popular so far but
like what what is the the downside so
what do you guys see as those risks
associated with it
um you know we focus solely on how can
we make the developers insanely
successful I almost say like how can we
make it rugless
the risk for me is actually more of just
like why I'm doing it which is I spent
15 years building on top of Twitter and
Facebook and SMS and every protocol in
the world and I spent 15 years getting
rugged and we built it just was our
first company we grew it to 100 million
people in two years in 2007 to 2010 and
we were like probably the first API
partner that ever like took Twitter data
out of Twitter to show like how you can
map a social address book and blackberry
bought it in 2010
and it was a meaningful acquisition you
know black it was 45 million bucks
Blackberry bought it cash it was a good
like thing it was only a 12 person team
small but like that moment of going
through history
we had just went through a lawsuit with
LinkedIn they seasoned assistance on the
API Twitter changed the API regulations
twice they cut off the app developers
and then I did this again because I'm I
don't know naive and just I just love
messaging and then I built the business
application that was the first ever
launch on Facebook Messenger WhatsApp
SMS etc for the last nine years I was
the CEO of assist and like
I think if we do that to developers we
will lose and we have to be able to
build trust with developers by making
them not have to trust us
and I really obsess over that
relationship because I've been there and
I watched the business models change
Twitter kind of started as an open
protocol and then it became the hardest
company to work with as a developer
Facebook changed everything on us and
then I have whole teams trying to keep
up or you're getting new API docs or new
laws and doing that for that long I
think over that community and
how hard it was
it needs to be the exact opposite it
needs to be like thousands of developers
in the way that we structure this makes
it permissionless anyone can plug in and
rugless and people are like this is an
amazing protocol to build with and for
me losing that Spirit or that
relationship or that trust within the
deaf Community to me is the biggest risk
of the whole thing yeah and why I'm
doing it like there's no point I I don't
want to do what I did like I had to deal
with in the past like I'm here because
there's a way to build an ecosystem
because of new technology that enables
it to centralize back-end so the next
twilios and whatsapps and biggest
companies in the world I get to meet
those Founders today and watch them
build the biggest companies in a way
that wasn't possible 10 years ago yeah
what else do you guys do to build trust
with the developer community
uh I mean we spend a ton of time here
we're at every single event building
with them uh we have a whole devex team
internally that is like trying to build
uh Widgets or protocols or put out
documents around like best practices
stuff like that design team is doing
design passes of how the brand should
look for other developers I do a monthly
call with how to fundraise for the
Developers
I'm like we need to get these companies
funded right the biggest problem they
have isn't I can't build product they're
actually all great product teams they're
like how do I raise money for the
product and so I'm sitting there being
like doing I did a one with like 35
people showed up at the last one and it
was all the some of the best Founders we
have and I'm just doing Q a what are we
struggling with raising money especially
in this market right and so helping them
build legitimate projects turn them into
real companies and just like then they
really trust us and we're enabling and
building those connections and I say
it's not up to us to convince developers
it's up to us to connect developers and
I think we're more about connecting the
ecosystem as well as the investors as
well as the talent as well as ourselves
than we are about convincing when you
think about building the business I
think what's really interesting is you
and Matt have spent a bunch of time
building a number of different companies
uh with great success like what are some
of the principles or or methodology that
you used as you went to go build this
company
um it's a good question I mean first off
is like we are kind of obsessed with
culture and the way we build the company
I mean we're a remote company but we
also are trying to build a company that
is a very productive but amazing place
to work and so all of our kind of perks
or the way we think about structuring
things is very much about giving people
time back not around like fluffy perks
and fancy offices what's an example we
give everyone a personal assistant
and so I did this in my last company I
was I was NSF trying to hire people out
of uh Facebook and Twitter's and you
know my VCS are like you need free lunch
and you need to do all the nap rooms and
whatever and I was like I'm spending so
much money on lunch and then I decided
to go remote first in 2014 and half the
company was remote from then on because
they left San Francisco it's kind of my
hack I'd hire them from Twitter downtown
because they wanted to leave and I'd let
him leave
um and I I called my assistant I was
like hey do you have other assistance
that I can offer so we have one
assistant for every like five employees
and everyone can use it but also for
their personal lives so if they wanted
to book an Airbnb for their family book
flights for their family find
babysitters order Groceries on instacart
whatever they want to do their life
doesn't stop at work so how can I help
them actually take care of their life so
they can just be more focused at work
and that ended up being a really
powerful thing and so we do the same
thing here we really focus on just like
giving people things that make them more
productive give them more time and more
well-being
um and just focused on doing great work
and having like that kind of environment
of a culture
um and that's what you guys do now is
you it's uh one for every five employees
or how do you it's more vague than that
right now everyone has access to an
assistant
um that you can use for anything and
then we scale it up based on like it's
funny that it's trying to teach
leadership as well like I'm very much
around leadership is about creating
other leaders and what that means is
giving control away and giving decision
making away and trying I think I'm
successful at this role if I make the
least amount of decisions and really
having that ethos and it's funny
watching people struggle to use an
assistant it's really hard for people to
give work away they're like I'm paid to
do this work I should like I'm like no
no if you don't like if you want to
focus on this work and give that away
why should you do that work and just it
kind of is almost a forcing function to
try to teach the behaviors we want to
see but it's it's a struggle people like
won't you know like I have to remind
people like hey you should you should
let someone else do that yeah and it's
cool to kind of like practice that with
people what are some other things like
giving everyone access to an assistant
that you guys do that may be different
than other companies
um
I'm I'm really uh kind of intentional
about Cadence and focus like on a pretty
obsessive amount and so every Monday
since the company started I write a
weekly dispatch with me and Matt and now
with our exec team and we write this
dispatch on last week this week and then
kind of what we're seeing in the
industry but the most important thing is
you know we're 89 dispatches in and
we've never missed a week since the day
with me and Matt started and it was just
me and Matt and I just take those like
written communication weekly Cadence and
everything in a weekly drum beat uh very
seriously and I think it matters and I
think that creating that momentum and
Cadence for everyone to just like really
feel like we can control that we can't
control if the market adopts how long
it's going to take Etc but we can
control if we're clearly communicating
every week and like never missing a week
when people receive that Weekly dispatch
what do you hope they do with it is it
just like for your information is it uh
something that they can then use
actionably that week like what's kind of
the desired impact
to highlight and see the impact they're
having on the organization is probably
the first and foremost I want people to
see the orgs or the teams they're
working on we know we're 32 people 33
people I want people to see the teams
and the orgs they're working on and the
impact it's having and I usually try to
tie that to the partners and what the
developers are doing with what we're
building I think tying together the
developers to our impact and work is the
thing I'd spend most of my time trying
to kind of tie together but we're
focused on a lot of what we're not doing
I spent a lot of time telling like
really you know our goal is to be the
default communication protocol for web3
that's our goal for the year and to
decentralize our operations and it's
that focus and a lot of people I think
are like doing tons of stuff and you
have logins and identity and all this
stuff like we're just a private and
secure DM layer like let's be the best
in the world at that because messaging
is the largest layer of the past
internet and I think it's going to be
the same
when you look at
um
the people that you're hiring are they
young people people with more experience
are they kind of crypto native are they
coming from web 2 like where have you
guys found success and what's
interesting to me is let's say you were
hiring all of the above right you put
those people together and like I think
the public narrative is that the crypto
native person is very different than
like the web 2 native person and so when
you put them together it might be
difficult right or even someone abrasive
in terms of their views of the world or
how they operate or their experience
level or whatever like what have you
guys found with 30 people like you
probably have enough of data points now
to kind of understand some of these
Dynamics totally I think one of the most
interesting things is I hired ahead of
people as our like 11th higher and
people would usually tell me that's way
too early
um and she's phenomenal
and I did it and you know Matt and I
like talked about it because I was like
we have to be able to be in education
company to get people out of web 2 into
web 3 to be really successful and we're
doing communication we're not just a
financial thing like I I wasn't you know
in crypto for 10 years building
Financial applications I was in
communication building messaging for 10
years and now I'm doing the same thing
and I think bringing uh that experience
with crypto native people and actually
how they work together our first uh
value at our company is curiosity we
celebrate what we don't know not what we
do
the reason is because it accelerates
learning and it accelerates
vulnerability to be more open that all
this shit's new and no one has any clue
what they're doing so as long as
we start there you can build a culture
of people being able to say I don't know
people will be able to raise their hand
and speak up when they actually have a
real problem people have a culture of
actually bring me the problems not the
solutions because the other way actually
doesn't allow people to end up working
on the problems and so we focus a lot on
that trust and bonding within the
culture so that we can hire actually
anyone and we have I think hired young
we were we were like man we call
ourselves a mature startup just because
like I'm not an asset I'm not in Miami I
don't have a loft I'm not like it's not
that at all it's like we're here to do
great work
um I'm not hanging out after work a lot
with a lot of people I mean we're kind
of remote but it's not like a me 25 in
San Francisco at 9pm like hey guys let's
shoot Papa shot in the office like it's
just not that kind of company and I
think I would call it a mature startup
and then our last offsite we just did
and uh out in Long Beach and I was like
dang this dude's like 24 percent he's
here this guy like we had a lot of Youth
in us and I was like oh this is great
but we're really trying hard to get that
how do you bring the cultures together
and have the right base of curiosity and
knowledge sharing and trust that enables
people to say what they don't know and I
think creating that environment is how
you make it successful what we have
found though is there are very specific
roles that you need a lot of crypto
experience the protocol research rule
the decentralization tokenomics there's
a ton of stuff that like you just like
we need it fast and we have to do this
in an accelerated timeline and I you you
know you can't take someone for three
years to go learn tokenomics and there
are people that have done that so I
think there are specialized rules where
we really do have to focus on people
with really uh crypto experience yeah
it's um it's fascinating to kind of
think about uh one of the things
I've seen recently that I it never
really hit me if you are
25 maybe 26 years old uh and you kind of
graduated out into the pandemic uh you
never worked in an office before
and so one of the things that uh
surprised me is we had somebody come and
visit uh who works for one of our
businesses as a young guy and he was
like walking around like Starry Eyed he
was like wait so like you guys all come
here like every day like yes like holy
like this is cool right and I was
telling somebody yesterday I was like it
hit me I was like you know once you do
it for a long time you're like office
right like you kind of almost like uh
become jaded to some degree yeah uh
but if you're like 23 to 25 years old
there is this element a little bit of
like I want to be around people right
and so like I think that some of these
companies that are remote first uh as I
talked to a lot of CEOs they're like
actually some of our people want
different experiences totally which then
brings this like hybrid thing and like
like it becomes a little bit less black
and white I think you know people want
to analyze it black and white
but if you've got your young people who
are like dude I got all the time or I
want to do 9 p.m pop a shot for sure
right like I don't got a family I don't
got to do like if not I'm gonna go
to the bar so I might as well hang on
people from work right uh versus and you
want them talking about it you want
those conversations correct right versus
the you know 45 year old who's like yo I
got three kids right I'm married I got
this going on whatever I'm worried about
my mortgage like that's a whole
different lifestyle right it's a whole
different uh kind of uh time management
and so when you have such different
experiences expectations Ambitions
whatever and you put them together like
maybe the right solution is actually
some sort of hybrid where people have
access to go and do things in person if
they want or there's off sites or like
like there's some Mobility to do stuff
like that but also it ends up being
remote first like how have you guys
thought about office remote you know
off-sites and kind of like what are the
Cadence and the way that people work
totally and I think and I've spent a lot
of time with remote work going remote
first to my last company and I worked
with Robert Stevens who's the founder of
Geek Squad who runs probably the largest
remote company in the world or created
it so I learned a lot from him and the
two things that we do here it's this is
culture stuff too I think it's about
enabling individuals to make choices by
giving them the funding to actually get
together so I have a policy or not I we
have a policy that everyone has a budget
per year to fly and spend time and meet
with anyone else and so we enable it and
we tell people you want to go one-on-one
and go work with someone in Portland you
have a co-working budget as well as a
stipend to travel for hanging out with
other people and so there was a meet up
in Vancouver like a few weeks ago and
like seven people were there for me I'm
going to New York on the 22nd because
there's seven people doing a New York
Meetup and so all these meetups are
happening so we're funding and enabling
kind of like these hubs and pods to
happen organically but we create the
budget and our head of people pushes
people to like go do this go make that
happen Don't Be The Loner like get it
get out meet people yeah and do it and
then we do two off-sites a year that are
much bigger right one in January very
one and going into H2 that are everyone
and bring everyone together and then
I think you also fund great home work
offices or a monthly stipend for
co-working if you want to be around
other people so our Vancouver office has
a few people in it actually we have a
few people in SF there's like five now
they're thinking about getting a pod and
so we we have a budget for if you want a
hub to form you can actually self-create
it so I think enabling that creating
budgets for it and championing it to
giving people the permission to do that
is something that is very powerful
because people that say remote is cool
or easier are totally full of it's
harder to lead remotely I actually love
being in an office I miss vibing
and running around in office but I
really love the ability to hire anyone
in the world and I won't trade the
ability to I can't imagine being on a
zoom call being like where do you live
to know if I could hire you and I think
that that is so much more valuable for
me to actually do the extra work to
write more communicate more be more
clear make sure we're all on the same
page give budgets for getting together
but it ain't cheaper I'll tell you our
off sites and our budgets to get
together is not cheaper than having an
office it's probably the same and it's
more work yeah so I just really I don't
think it's like this magic bullet type
thing where like yeah we can just work
anywhere what about like meeting Styles
or like communication right is do you
guys work asynchronous asynchronously do
you have
um kind of uh remote first meetings
where everyone's on their computer even
if they're in person like how does that
stuff work yeah uh everyone's on the
computer even though they're in person
that's been something I've done for
almost 10 years now changed everything
for me that was really the moment when
we had two offices New York SF and half
the team remote
the big meeting room of people
and then the remote people on the TV was
10 times worse than everyone's on their
own computer and we're all equal and
that was a big change so I still we
still do that and require that no matter
what
um if I think about the
kind of culture of communication we're
very async we're like a GitHub culture
you know if we're a protocol like it's a
very technical thing
um but we still we work in slack you
know but my co-founder Matt is way more
tool crazy yeah yeah I'm like I've known
that for a while I know he is I'm very
simple and I'm like to like okay we can
like chill out let's write the comms
let's do the thing Matt is like you know
19 different widgets wired up with the
notification blocker and just like I'm
jealous of how he's figured all this out
because I can't imagine how much time it
takes to figure it all out but like he
showed me some of it before and it's
like yeah like yeah it's it's better if
you can figure it out it just takes a
long time and you gotta try a lot of
things I think to figure out what
doesn't work as well yeah I think what I
wanted people to know is they can design
and control their attention however they
see fit like when you work with us
however works for you is what should be
how it works and you should just be
clear on these are my hours that I'm off
this day I don't do any meetings I block
full snooze all day like whatever
however you work I don't care like I I
work really well in the morning middays
I get distracted like I want people to
know that they have the permission and
freedom to design their day how they
want as an individual I think that's the
most important thing which leads to an
asynchronous communication culture and
we do one Friday weekly wrap up that
that let's try I literally I'm running
back to the hotel and it's uh an hour
meeting every Friday that we do on a
Eastern Time Zone globally and it's all
recorded and we use rewatch I don't know
if you've heard of rewatch what is that
it was built by a GitHub old GitHub team
that's kind of like grain and it's it
allows you to every meeting is recorded
and every meeting can be turned into
like like almost like an Instagram story
can be commented you can have
conversations around you break out any
transcript of it and anything that
happens within the organization in an
asynchronous way can start a
conversation or be turned into content
to then be shared and that it's insane
like the re-watch platform is nuts
um in one of our
um protocol Engineers Naomi she came she
I think she worked on it and she's like
we have like you you have to use this
it's one of those tools where like you
have to get your whole company on it
it's on every Zoom call it's a big like
it's a it's a it's like a slack it like
it's like okay we're going in we gotta
like do this we're setting up we're
signing a contract and then once you get
into it it's like how did we operate
without this it's one of those tools and
I don't have those very often you know
like Matt has them daily you know like I
have them like every three years I'm
like slack was one this isn't one where
I'm like oh yeah like the ability to
have a conversation or turn any meeting
easily into a beautiful
two second or two minute clip where then
we're having a conversation around it
and it just works and it's all
integrated with notion and et cetera
like it's pretty powerful yeah where can
we send people to find out more about
the protocol if they want to learn
xmtp.org and when they go there what is
the best way for them if they're
building something to actually kind of
start using it totally so it's all open
source and there's sdks for all mobile
apps there's
um a kind of Open Source JS app for the
web you can Fork our inbox so we have a
full inbox product xmtp.chat if you want
to literally go to xmtp.chat right now
and just sign in with your wallet and
say Shane mac.ie if you can send me a
message it'll go to my Converse app and
so you can actually use it but that all
the applications we build are forkable
and you can use them because they're all
open source and they're just basically
resource clients for developers and so
you can go use right now and you can I'm
Shane back on Twitter as well so what do
you tweet about
me just whatever's on my mind I try to
tweet less I try to like if I was in it
I try to like you know
just
Twitter was like a snark engine for me
10 years ago right uh and now I just try
to have more optimism and just bring
more curiosity to the world I think you
know maybe you get older maybe I get
more boring I don't know I'm the same
way but it was amazing less imposter
syndrome you know you're not running
around pounding your chest being like Oh
no this shit's you know great I'm like I
really want to build a great company and
I think like thinking about long-term
things talking about them on Twitter
having a longer term view so that
everyone can be on with it being a
little calmer with that
um you know I've been a part of like a
massive failure we did zarly we blew
like 40 million dollars in three years
and that everyone hated it I hated it
and it was like my fault that was in
2010 and then like gist was a success
but I was really lucky and young like I
didn't I wasn't the CEO ta was and he's
amazing and like
I picked the right that picked the right
Captain you know and I learned and uh
got into the space and then assist uh
was great and I was doing that for
almost nine years of my life doing
business messaging on top of these
protocols but you sell it it's not a
venture outcome when you sell something
at a choir for 50 million bucks after a
merger some investors are like oh you
got you know a little bit some your
employees don't do that well like you
have these exits in the Venture world
and you just start over
and your lose your whole team and I I
was as obsessed of culture at my last
company as I am at this one and I have
the most amazing team ever and I'm like
all that just goes away and so for me
like what I tweet about is trying to
think about how to create something
enduring and not sell something and us
have like a 10-year Vision here so that
we're kind of like
building something that can last like I
really just like if I have to sell again
and start over like it's it wasn't the
choice it was kind of like you know just
the market and it had to yeah
um and I just really am inspired to
build something that's lasting yeah I
think you're doing a great job uh trying
xmtp yeah xmtv like SMTP but with the
next dot org and Shane Mack on Twitter
yeah thanks dude thank you so much for
coming all right uh I think not only
it's fun to talk but also like the work
you guys are doing is very important and
um I think it's unclear to a lot of
people why it's important but over time
kind of you know uh it'll come into
Clarity and we need as many people as
possible building privacy enhancing
technology but doing it in a way that
isn't like hey come use my product and
like screw everything else but actually
building
um kind of infrastructure where anyone
can come in they can use it they can
Fork uh the open source software they
can build applications on top of it like
really try to kind of uh you know arm
the rebels right if you will if you if
you kind of take the Shopify uh phrase
and um it just feels like you guys are
kind of doing that uh and being
intentional about the way you're doing
it uh which I really appreciate so
thanks so much for uh for kind of
exploring everyone we're trying into and
I think if you think about our just the
mission of enabling everyone to own
their communication I think it's such a
powerful thing and the applications then
can people don't have to know that
really that's what's happening
underneath but you are more protected
and then if you do want to leave
something or you do have a change of
feelings about the leadership or
something does happen you can take your
identity your network and your
conversations with you is like the most
powerful thing that we could give people
and for crypto itself in web 3 in the
wallet I think sign in with wallet is
way more cool than log in with Facebook
and the ability for people to own that
and for me just working on that and
working towards that as like a mission
and a vision for us
and really
for crypto itself crypto is still small
I actually wonder if owning your
communication will be way bigger than
owning your assets
I think that there's a shot
awesome thank you so much for doing this
and we'll definitely be together future
oh anytime man